Hello Freak bitches.
It is interesting how the fat patterns
does shrink up.
There's three major fat distributions,
right?
You got your depo fat.
That's like the love handles are with
women.
Sometimes it's the saddlebags and the
side of the thigh.
Sometimes you'll see a women and the
upper back or the tricep area with guys.
That's usually it.
But la.
Yeah,
or the belly or the love handles for
most guys,
you know,
then you have internal fat.
That's the dangerous stuff.
They a intra abdominal fat that got fat.
That's what,
that's what can kill you.
Uh,
then you have subcutaneous fat.
It's like the smooth fat underneath the
skin,
like a,
like an insulation layer.
And then of course they've identified
that Brown fat also,
it's like a act of fat.
It produces heat in the body.
It's like part of the survival
mechanism.
Back when our ancestors had to tolerate
a lot of extremes in temperatures like
cold,
you have this brown fat,
it's like an metabolically active fat
and uh,
it's,
it's kids have it,
but by the time you're like 12,
it almost disappears because you know,
we have this,
uh,
regulated temperatures all the time.
People don't expose themselves to cold.
They're always bundling up and the homes
are overheated.
But,
um,
but a lot of people were saying,
now you can actually get that
metabolically active fat.
The brown fat sal's gone,
which helps keep you mean,
uh,
and helps burn the other yellow fat.
So cold showers,
cold water treatments,
um,
exposing yourself to cold,
a real good thing for develop that and
uh,
the brown fat and build your immune
system and you,
you have a much better tolerance to cold
and much less likely to get a innovated
in cold weather.
So you don't have a tendency to come
down with colds or flu and stuff like
really brown fat,
Brown fat.
I'd never heard of that before.
What is it created by?
Like what it's in your,
uh,
it's,
some of it's in the peritoneal cavity.
Some of it's a up in the neck,
uh,
area.
Uh,
and it's,
it's just something that nature provided
to help temperature regulation,
helping tolerate cold.
So is that like more common with inuits
and folks who live in?
Oh yeah,
for sure.
They have well developed brown fat.
But you and I could do it too if we just
expose yourself a little bit more to the
cold.
He's a narcissism thing.
Just the idea that I should be in charge
is all presidents are probably crazy.
I don't think anybody should be
president.
I really don't think that it should be
an option.
I think the computer,
yeah.
I mean when we,
we'll probably get there in the next 20
years.
We have a computer we program in all of
our laws,
you know,
and we were like,
okay,
now,
you know,
make the right choice.
Yeah.
But it's programmed by people and people
can influence the programming.
I mean that was one of the big deals
with electronic voting machines,
right?
No,
we have that computer be built by a
computer.
Oh,
well then we're fucked because he
computer's just going to take over.
Then it's like what Elon Musk is worried
about George P.
Bush.
She look at that.
That's going to be the next,
he's going to be of a lazy eye.
The left eye.
The Kennedy,
somebody punched him.
Can you tell it?
He had a lazy eye.
Yeah.
I dated a girl,
had a lazy eye.
NFM Lazy.
Lazyeyes sexy for a short period of
time.
She was kind of a freak.
She was a frequent lazy eye.
I developed a lazy eye fetish for at
least a year.
Did you?
Yeah.
So the very small youporn search.
Well,
why are glasses hot girls with glasses
or hot,
you know,
girls would,
crutches aren't hot.
Like why is some disabilities hot?
You know the girl with glasses is
something sexy about like,
how is this like a library?
It's like a older authority,
fake glasses or authority.
Who is that what it is?
Someone is reading so much.
Their eyes go bad.
Yeah.
Look at that hot pitch you came even
see,
plus you could take your glasses off,
your ugly.
She didn't even know
she could feel you though.
If you're fat and ugly,
she'd be like,
Damn Shit,
you feel me?
She can't go the glasses and no hands.
There you go.
Feel your weight on top for it up.
Yeah.
She wraps her legs around you like what
does all this fucking fat slob?
What are you talking about?
You don't have handguns were being picky
for it,
but that was my mother's fucking main
thing was numbers,
numbers in Harlem,
so I got to walk around there as a
child.
Then as I got older,
my first arrest wasn't home.
I got caught smoking weed on 160 first
street in 1983 the first day after the
superbowl,
I want $800 on the triple.
What's the Miami?
These,
the,
the sleeping,
the bees,
whatever the fuck they were when they
beat the redskins and I wanted to a
health food store.
In those days we'd stores were health
food stores in Harlem.
So what does the health food store can
complain of you who's no protein drinks.
In those days it was crude protein
powder,
you know,
vitamins.
And then if you knew the right people,
you want to know you're not in the
glasses wall bulletproof.
Wow.
And you went in and they,
you'd say,
what do you have?
Let me get to raise,
and they,
excuse me,
they put the weed in the glass.
You'd take and give him the $30 and
you'd ask permission,
can I roll it in the corner?
And your role,
the joint,
the corner,
and then you could go outside and smoke
it.
I rolled it in the corner and when I lit
it in the corner,
because it was windy,
it was January when I went to put the
light into the joint,
a fucking mailman put a gun to my head
and he goes,
get on the floor.
He goes,
if you got more than 20 singles on you,
I'm going to beat the fuck outta here.
I got on the floor,
I had 800 I had one 800 probably at
seven 40 and he goes,
what'd you get this money from me?
And also in cops started pulling up and
they were looking for people who was
selling loose joints.
The kids two blocks away.
So when they realized I lived in Jersey
and I had no idea in those days,
I didn't walk with an ID dog.
My word was my shit.
No idea.
In those days I throw away the ID,
fucking no idea.
You want to,
you're a cop,
figure it out the fuck you're fucking
Kadri figure it out.
And the cop told me,
tell me the truth,
your name.
I told him the truth and they put my
finger on one of those things.
That was the early technology,
New York hat,
Lake three vans that have that shit on
it.
Fingerprint thing,
scanner.
And it came back,
Jose Diaz and blast,
they let me go.
In fact,
the cop took wheat out of my bag,
put it on the floor and said,
now it's nine grams.
I you could keep it and I'll give you a
ticket.
And that was my first legitimate arrest.
I got arrested for that and Manhattan.
I did six months,
the first sentence and I moved to
Colorado and I had to write the guy a
letter on the first and call them on the
fifth and they let me go.
All right.
Have you seen that white kid with
tattoos on his face?
He calls himself stitches.
No.
Oh,
I'm going to find you your new favorite
song.
Okay,
that sounds good,
Jay.
This is breaking your face brick.
It's got 5 million hits.
America is in trouble.
Now what you're going to do with it,
that's what you get.
I'm saying it's going to be all day.
It's going to be in your head now.
What's going to do with it now?
What?
You're going to give me my new tagline
after I submit people?
Yeah.
Now what you're going to do with it.
That's rude.
Carrie,
Tony and Terry.
You first you win and then just stick it
into the white guy was a hell raiser
guy.
You know what I mean?
I think that was him.
I think that was him with a mascot that
was supposed to be him saying,
I've just,
my interpretation of the aura,
I think he should have,
he should have stayed a hundred percent
black shit.
Hell raiser kind of brought it back to
white people because black people don't
like hell raiser and we should've been
spawn or starting.
You know?
That's a very good point because hell
raiser was a white guy in the movie,
and black people hate scary movies.
Generally speaking.
I'm sure love scary movies generally.
Yeah.
As all stereotypical,
stereotypical generalizations of how to
raise a people,
you gotta be able to generalize because
if you can't generalize and you can't
make any fucking points,
that's so true.
You know what I mean?
You can't make any punch.
I know.
I know one guy that doesn't do that.
Like,
yes,
I know a guy too,
but generally,
Jesus Christ.
That's one of the things before you say
what you just said,
you go,
yeah,
I know this might sound a little bit
racist,
but.